this is the sea glider by startup Regent
it's kind of a cross between an electric
seaplane a hydrofoil and a vessel that
uses something called Wing in-ground
effect don't worry I'll explain that
later now this Tech could give you a new
way to rapidly commute between coastal
cities and to try and Achieve that aim
Regent tell me they have been conducting
tests and taking pre-orders to the tune
of seven billion dollars but where you
see a sea glider flying could give you a
good indication of how successful Regent
might be right now this doesn't quite
look like this and that's just one
reason why it's not quite there yet so
as always we're going to look at where
Regent is now where it wants the sea
glider to be and then examine what it
needs to do to get there but let's start
with where it wants to be
the idea behind Regent's electric sea
glider is to develop a kind of new mode
of Transport based on combining existing
Concepts to create a zero emission way
of carrying up to 12 passengers up to
180 miles for around 60 dollars per
passenger here's Regent's CEO Billy
talheimer we're talking about you know
Hawaii the Caribbean uh Japan New
Zealand right these are sort of key
markets that are coastly distributed now
you may be wondering why Regent is
trying to invent a whole new mode of
transport to replace planes and ferries
when there are already companies trying
to develop electric planes and ferries
well it's because that Wing in ground
effect can extend your range when we fly
low over the surface of the water we're
flying on a cushion of air this is what
Pelicans fly on or other birds at Sea
flying low to the water it's
aerodynamically advantageous and so
that's why you get these range
extensions when the vessel is in a
harbor it deploys a hydrofoil to provide
increased maneuverability at lower
speeds interestingly the sea glass is
considered a maritime vessel and so is
regulated by Maritime agencies and not
the aviation Authority that could mean
skipping airport security but Billy told
me he also believed that it would give a
faster path to certification the company
also said that the Viceroy could be
applied to other Maritime roles like oil
rig maintenance cargo transfer and Naval
operations and while Regents say their
starting range will be 180 miles the
company plans to extend the range of the
Viceroy to 500 Miles when next
Generation batteries become available
that's LA to San Francisco that's Boston
to New York that's sold to Jeju in South
Korea remember this we'll be coming back
to it later
so we're a regent right now well in
September the company conducted their
first test flight using a quarter scale
model of the sea glider Regent also told
me they'd received some 400 pre-orders
half of which were from Mesa Air Group
with others coming from small Airlines
like Southern Airways Express and some
European Ferry companies while some of
these pre-orders come with firm deposits
others are just an intention to buy and
Hawaiian Airlines have invested in
region though they haven't placed an
order yet and to try and make sure it
can actually deliver sea gliders Regent
is developing a manufacturing facility
in Rhode Island where it hopes to begin
by making 12 gliders a year with the
help of a multi-million dollar State
incentive
so if they've conducted tests received
orders and secured a grant to build a
factory why is sea glider not quite
there yet well firstly they still need
to build and test a full-scale version
of the sea glider and then prove that it
can safely carry passengers secondly the
company has to transition from proof of
concept to full-scale manufacturing and
right now that's something that many
electric transport startups have
struggled with and then there's those
500 mile range ambitions see to get from
180 miles of range which is still
hypothetical for now to 500 Miles you'd
need a 175 increase in your battery
capacity now recently I've been chatting
to some battery manufacturers and they
told me they're expecting an increase of
just 30 percent in capacity by 2027. so
if that battery increase doesn't emerge
it will limit the routes that sea glider
can operate in not only will that
exclude that lucrative LA to San
Francisco route but it will also keep
them in direct competition with other
electric aircraft which are expected to
have a range of around 150 miles but can
fly over land our business model is not
based on those batteries coming to
fruition we have customers today within
this 180 mile range that can use
existing batteries
so for sea glider to take off Regent is
going to need to build test and certify
a full-scale version of its vessel pivot
from testing to manufacturing and
finally begin delivery of some of those
pre-orders if the company achieves all
that then don't be surprised if you see
these things out in the wild conducting
some short Journeys but as for the
company's Ambitions of getting you from
LA to San Francisco Well for now you
might be better off getting a normal
plane as you could be waiting quite some
time for that Battery Technology to
develop
foreign